hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice intense manoeuvring game between
alpha zero and stock fish unlike a
couple of previous videos between alpha
zero in stock fish that were from the
opening book that was used in TCC 2016
this one does not contain any any prior
opening knowledge and it is everything
just you know play play whatever you
want and it's interesting for some
reason stock fish again goes for the
Queen's Indian defense even though it
lost the plenty of games tall 4-0
already using the same defense but
regardless I'm sure you're all gonna
enjoy the game as it features a lot of
things you can use in your own games but
before we check out the actual game I
would like to take this opportunity to
invite all of you to a very nice story
now I was having a beer with my
brother-in-law yours out of you might
know him he also runs a chess channel as
you can see he is currently at some 921
subscribers and he told me that he is
preparing a very nice video about the
outside past porn now there are a lot of
videos already on YouTube regarding the
outside passport but he said that he's
been studying the outside passed pawn
intensely and that he is ready to share
some very nice secrets about the outside
passed pawn you know how it could be a
weakness could be a strength and so on
so I invite you to check it out I will
put the first thing we will see in the
description below will be a link to his
channel so feel free to check it out
check out his content and if you enjoyed
it feel free to subscribe I thought as
tomorrow is you know Christmas it would
be a very nice Christmas present that
surpassed 1000 subscribers on such a day
and also today is his wife's birthday so
feel free to congratulate him about that
as well if you can spare a minute that
being said let's check out our game
alpha zero has two white pieces and we
have a d4 on the board Knight to f6 c4
e6 and now comes the Knight to f3 and
for some reason stockfish doesn't know
it's the latest trend to transpose into
the Queens gambit declined so b6 we have
the Queen's Indian defense for I don't
know for the well her considering they
played probably millions of games this
is a millionth time for for stock first
but we've seen already at least 15 games
work the Queen's Gambit the client the
the Queen's Indian defense was played g3
we have the shot to be 7th in Cairo in
the light square Bishop as is often the
case here black once they control of d4
square Bishop to G to Bishop to e7 this
is all standard theory of the Queen's
Indian defense nice to see three and now
comes castles alpha also castles we have
Knight to e4 offering a trade of nights
here Bishop to d2 and now comes d5 sorry
not d6 but the d5 and this has all been
played before this is still considered
standard book theory of the Queen's
Indian defense C capture Sundy 5e
capture Sun d5 and here we have Queen to
b3
this for example is a move wisely one
who played in 2015 in the world rapid
championship against Anton core above
and core above played Knight captures on
the two and horrible one a very nice
game if I took really attacked like like
a madman but core ball defended properly
and in the end won the game I always say
Coral Bob is really an amazing player so
whenever you get a chance to check out
the game by on tone core above you know
feel free to do it you will not be sorry
but here we have a new move by stockfish
c5 and now we have a completely new game
c5 in this position has not been played
before and here alpha goes Bishop to f4
basically saying that quarter boast
Knight captures and e2 was a good move
as alpha does not allow this capture
with Knight to a successful fish keeps
developing
perhaps this Knight can come to the b4
in the future or or perhaps let's say c7
b5 and then and then what not depending
on what a what Alpha plays rook F 2 d1
and now comes c4 and this c4 is the most
exciting moment in the game not the most
exciting but it's a really exciting
moment because it's really a committal
move for example you could also capture
here but that doesn't really gain
anything after Knight captures you just
improve the
the position of whites pieces let's say
captures captures and then better up
twelve six you put the bishop on on this
very nice diagonal white moves the Queen
and still white will have a very
comfortable game here so you you we're
gonna go with the old to take is a
mistake
if you're not gaining anything stockfish
instead place c4 and this is a very
committal move yes you have created a
very strong c4 pawn but the base of the
punch in the d5 pawn is now very weak
and this is what alpha will use as as a
like a homing beacon for hope for the
rest of the game and it's gonna be very
enjoyable Queen to c2 now we have
Knights to be for attacking the Queen
once again Queen C 1 and now Queen to d7
and here you see stockfish has a knight
on d4 and e4 Stockbridge still has the
bishop pair the rooks are yet to be
developed wherever and it seems that
stockfish gains a lot of space here also
the point is you know quite a nuisance
here on c4 and alpha goes h4 and it
really seems like yeah whenever there is
like doubt or anything just push push h4
seems 11 Aragon was right all along
rook 8 the c8 stockfish keeps developing
at some point white might decide to the
challenge black c4 pawn which would be
three and you know having a row conceit
is always very nice we have a three
attacking the knight here Knight
captures and c3b captures on c3 and now
comes Knight back to c6 so here we have
a case of white c3 pawn being weak but
also blacks d5 point is very weak and it
will be interesting to see how black
will go about this week c3 pawn and how
alpha will deal with the week d5 pawn
queen to b1 and okay perhaps some ideas
like Queen to b5 offering a quick Queen
trade are possible in the future
rook see th now the rook is no longer
useful in the C file and now comes Luke
to e1 perhaps alpha has some sorry ideas
of pushing efore in the future as both
the Queen and the rook are controlling
d4 square
Knight to a5 this B 3 square would now
be a very nice outpost for black's
knight
but now comes a move that well seems
like seems like an obvious move Knight
to g5 years you are threatening
checkmate and it seems like a useless
move of course the black will deal with
this threat but also you're forcing
black to deal with it now how you're
gonna deal with it will you push g6 will
you push f5 will you capture the night
here if you capture the night then
you've just given up the bishop prepared
without really gaining anything not
really something you want to do
perhaps ideas like King H to brush up to
h3 are coming and white will control a
lot of important squares so here black
deals with it with f5 okay you've closed
this diagonal and now alpha goes back
Knight to f3
now the e5 square becomes a very you
know convenient Bishop to f6 and now
comes rope to a2 we have h6 by L by
stockfish and now even a four okay
Queen to e6 and now comes King to h2 a
very nice idea alphas plan here is to
push h5 and create a very strong outpost
for his knight on g6
and it's very interesting now comes
Bishop to see the bishop is no longer
useful in this diagonal as there's no
pressure at the moment against the d5
pawn but now comes look to h1 very nice
move Knight to Knight back to c6 and now
comes h5 and here it's very interesting
what happens if stockfish decides to
attack this pawn would let's say Queen
to f7 then Bishop to d6 is very strong
you attack the rook and now even though
this comes with check after the King
moves the Queen is under attack Queen
has to move and now you're just gonna
get rid of this rook and you wrap the
exchange and you will have a much better
game so here
stop the first place King to h8 makes
room for the rook on g8 so now Bishop to
d6 in the future if the Queen attacks
the pawn will not be such a problem we
have Knight to g1 a very nice move the
g6 square is a very nice outpost for
whites night but if you play Knight to
h4 then black can eliminate it with the
bishop so White's plan is next nice the
g1 to h3
then the dark square Bishop will move
from there for then tonight comes to f4
then to g6 and then hopefully at some
point it will come to the very
central square e v if nothing is traded
by them
so with Knights the g1/s planned
Queen to have seven attacking the pawn
but now comes Bishop to f3 the knight
adjust freed DF three square for the
white Bishop so now the bishop is
guarded we have looked back to d8 now
taking away the d6 Square from the
bishop and now comes Knight to h3 as
planned King back to g8 and now as this
Bishop has to move to make a room for
the night we noticed this beautiful
diagonal so what do you play here Bishop
the c1 the bishop is now ready to come
to a3 rook f d8 not allowing this to
count with an attack on the rook how
about also putting pressure against
White's e to pawn queen to b5 now a very
nice maneuver with the Queen as the
knight on c6 is still unguarded Bishop
to b7 defending and now comes looked to
d1 we have nice to a5 again hoping to
bring the knight over to be three but
now Queen back to b1 as the f5 point is
also unguarded
bushra back to ca defending here the
pawn and now comes Knight to f4 so here
you can see that white did all of this
maneuvering with the night the night was
on f3 came to g1 came to h3 came to f4
now it can come to g6 and all of this
without black actually making any
progress because there is no progress to
be made and this is what fascinates me
about this game so much that when black
pushed this pawn from c5 to c4 yes black
said now your c3 pawn is weak but it
also made a very committal move that
well it's really not able to make any
progress so it's you know a double-edged
sword this c4 move Bishop to g5 now and
now comes Knight to g6 of course alpha
does not allow this night to be trade
for the Bishop Bishop captures on c1 we
have Queen captures on c1 and now Bishop
to e6 putting more defense to the d5
pawn and now finally comes Knight to e5
so this is one ambitious night you know
traveling all the way from f3 of course
it couldn't go from F 3 at the e5
immediately black would just capture
with the bishop
to require this a very nice journey G 1
H 3 F 4 g 6 and only then after the dark
square bishop SAR traded and now alpha
brings the knight over to e5 and now
this is this becomes a monster night
Queen to c7 hopefully now this a
five-night can either be traded for this
night or it will find some use on b3
rook to be 2 now alphas plan is like we
said from the beginning
black pushed C for alpha wants to make
d5 a target so alpha is planning rook to
b5 to actually attack it with the rook
we have Knight back to b7 and now comes
Luke to b5 as planned
Knight back to a5 stock fish simply
waits to see what will happen and now
comes Queen to f4
we have Knight to b3 and now comes
Knight to g6 offering a queen trade and
here a stock fish is not allowed to
trade Queens because after Knight
captures on before and i-4 there's a
triple attack against the d5 pawn and
even if you play something like king of
seven first alpha will improve III not
allow e 2 to stay a target and then
after any move black makes wife will
simply start grabbing material captures
captures captures captures and with
being up a pawn in a better position
alpha should win this game so after
Knight to g6 we have Queen to c6 and now
comes the Queen to e5 so slowly but
surely alpha improves the position and
now you might say okay but what if a sex
doesn't that bother this rook doesn't
seem like it's very comfortable there
but yeah rope to b4 and there's really
no way to further attack this rope
you only have a light square bishop and
the night it doesn't really have all
that many ways to attack the rook if you
attack it further row b5 and again there
will be so much pressure against this d5
pawn the Knights can come to f4 and then
there will be the d5 pawn will be
attacked four times so not really
possible
so after Queen to e5 we have Queen to d7
simply waiting see what happens also the
d5 point is nicely defendant we have III
you know taking care of any any future
weaknesses Knight back to a5 and now
comes Bishop - G - perhaps freeing the
square of three for the night if needed
Knight back to b7 and now come
look to a-1 king - h7 and now comes
Knight to f4
we have Bishop to g8 and now comes a
move that alphas been planning it seems
like an odd decision here trapping your
own queen like that but alpha has
everything planned out rook captures on
d5 and now you don't have the option of
playing rook captures on e5 because rook
captures on d7 or look captures and then
after pawn captures here
the attack against the b7 Knight and
also this the threat of this pawn coming
to e6 is too overwhelming for black to
handle even though the material is equal
on the board but now after we move
tonight let's say Knight c5 Bishop to h3
comes there is no way to actually defend
this as e 6 is coming so here you would
have to play something like Trudy - but
then but she captures King h8 and now e
6 will be too great to stop even if you
capture Kim G - Kim Jiwon attacks the
rook rook moves now comes Nagi six check
he moves Knight here check King moves
and now he simply pulled upon the f7 is
guarded by the night so no Bishop to f7
is possible you are unable to prevent
this pond from queening and the game is
over so here after rook captures on d5
you cannot capture the Queen you have to
play Bishop captures on d5 and this is
what alpha had in mind Queen captures on
d5 and again if you captured in Bishop
captures you're just gonna lose more
central pawns
so after Queen captures on d5 we have
Knight to d6 but here alpha finds a way
to trade Queens nevertheless bushel to
h3 are putting pressure on the f5 pawn
rook to e7
now this rook will at some point to be
able to come to c7 - defended the c4
pawn Knight to g6 attacks the rook rook
to f7 and now Knight to e5 attacks the
Queen and the rook but stockfish has it
all figured out Queen to b7 now you
cannot capture the rook as your queen on
d5 is hanging but alpha never intended
to gain material equality it just wanted
to you know sacrifice the exchange and
have a lot of central pawns Bishop to G
- and now comes the Queen captures
Bishop captures on d5 attacking the rook
and now comes rook to c7 so okay the
knight and Bishop are attacking the c4
pawn but
tonight Andrew car also defending the c4
pawn so white cannot grab it just yet
and now comes King to g2 we have Knight
to e4 going after the weak c3 pawn but
alpha says no problem but captures pawn
captures and now comes f3 pawn captures
King captures on f3 and now you see
where alphas compensation lies yes stock
fish is up the exchanger but alpha has a
very strong night and the the c3 pawn
that's basically the weakest link in
this pawn chain is guarded by black
stone c4 pawn so now all alpha has to do
is push push to connected pass pawns
so that's compensation you know for the
exchange route to e7
we have Knight to g6 attacking the rook
rook to b7 and now comes Eve or as of
course like Josh Waitzkin always said
passports must be pushed
we have b5 a captured son b5 route
capture son b5 and now comes Knight to
f4 protecting the h5 pawn rook the b3
and now comes Knight to e2 protecting
again the c3 pawn now you don't really
gain anything by going after the pawn
once again because the wife can always
prevented with E 5 so rook to e8
protecting the a7 point but now e 5 and
now stockfish starts pushing its own
passed pawn
we have d5 pushing another pass pawn a4
we have d6 a3 and now comes the d7 and
now you already have to start dealing
with the past d7 pawn King to g8 we have
rook to d1 and now comes Luke beat b8
white simply pushes East 6 we have King
to eat King to f8 preparing King to e7
and if black was will be able to play
King g7 such a nice blockading move then
perhaps the black will still have
growing chances but alpha doesn't allow
it
and there is one move that ends the game
on the spot off of this plate but you
know feel free to pause the video and
try to find this move that alpha plate I
will just have a nice sip of my water
here
so for those of you who were able to
find it congratulations you are really
you know in for a wonderful Christmas
and for those of you just won't enjoyed
show the movies of course Knight to d4
Knight to f4 is also possible but then
you you just allow blacks to go to e7
but Knights the d4 doesn't allow it
because here King to e7 is met with
Knight to c6 check this fork ends the
game immediately so on the other hand
after Knight to d4 which is the move
Alfa played stockfish resigned in this
position rather it failed to make a
movie in some reasonable time that it
was allowed but now after any anything
you try let's say a to still you get
Knight to c6 and now comes let's say you
bring a queen into the game it doesn't
work because you capture capture and now
after captures there's no way to prevent
Queenie King e7 Knight check skiing
capture so now there's a queen brought
into the game and then the other hand
after Knight to c6 if you don't start
with bringing a queen into the game
let's say try rope to be one which seems
like an excellent move you know
yeah sure you bring a queen I'm just
gonna grab it with my rook and then I'm
gonna Queen this pawn it doesn't work
because it's actually a forced checkmate
in two you will simply bring even a rook
will suffice that this comes with check
black has to capture there are no other
moves and after captures this rook
delivers checkmate as the knight and
pawn are creating a wall here against
the black King as you can see here so
this would be checkmate and the game of
course would be over but stockfish
didn't border after Knight to d4
stockfish failed to make a move and
therefore it resigned so that's the game
at the I do hope you enjoyed it a very
nice manoeuvring game quite quite quite
an enjoyable one one I hope you agree
and yeah like I said the first thing you
will see in below will be a link to your
serves channel feel free to check it out
and you know do subscribe if you if you
enjoy it I would like to thank Martin
and Paul Hearst Peter Rose Dave Attell
and Sam Leonard for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video series thank all for
watching and I will see you soon most
likely on Christmas I might even have a
short stream
tomorrow morning we'll see how it goes
but I'll definitely just you know at
least throw a puzzle or something so so
you know we have a nice Christmas video
everybody thank you all and hopefully I
will see you soon